what's up squad you guys have been
asking me all about the season 7 trailer
when are we going to actually see some
footage it looks like we found out when
that's going to happen first we got to
talk about what's going on and then what
they did last year look at the way they
drop trailers the content that they had
in those so this will be a really cool
trip down WTF memory lane now our
trailer watch begins if you're new to
the channel I do weekly Game of Thrones
videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'm even doing a giveaway
right now that I'll explain at the end
of the video but the reason we haven't
seen the teaser or trailers so far is
just because filming has been pushed so
much but that's all going to change
really soon so HBO does a couple
different things when is teasing new
seasons we got a real brief look like a
couple frames during an HBO trailer for
stuff that's coming up this spring that
included girls all the other TV shows
that it says they did the funny Jon
Oliver not a game of Thrones Game of
Thrones trailer everybody was so
confused by that it was almost like a
joke about them not having a game of
Thrones trailer and using that to
promote John Oliver which is a great
show I'll play that in a second it's a
funny trailer
in 2017
HBO's biggest Sunday night show we turn
oh wait oh I'm sorry
you meant yeah not you right yesterday I
heard your voice and I assumed that
biggest you did but by this time last
year we had already seen a number of
teasers and even a little bit of new
footage so what it sounds like HBO is
doing is bringing their genuine first
teaser to South by Southwest in March
that's happening March 12th so it's on
par with what they did last year even
though they were two and a half months
ahead of where they are this year but
there were a couple different types of
teams they released last year the first
real teaser for season six was that ink
is dry three-eyed Raven voiceover clip
where he's basically talking about the
past not being able to change it but
being able to change the future the
watch we listen in David
the past is already written
the ink is dry
they have no idea what's going to happen
very cryptic but even though there
wasn't a lot of new footage it conveyed
a lot of information we learned about
the Jedi training that he was giving to
brand there was a lot of theories about
time travel because we knew from the
books even if they're going to be
changing things that he could still use
the weirwoods to see visions of things
that had happened in the past so there
were a lot of rumors about flashbacks
that were happening in this just
seemingly confirmed that then a couple
weeks after that in January like late
January they released the three banner
teasers for House Stark House Lannister
in House Targaryen
[Music]
we have mine
from instinct
every one of us is poor and powerless
and yet together
we can overthrow an empire
you fall back
your rock moccasin years
for me really the whole point of those
was just to show the conflicts that each
of those protagonists was going to face
because Cersei is still kind of a
protagonist in her own story even though
she's an antagonist when you look at the
other characters you had a Ramsay pink
letter teaser throwing the gauntlet down
to Jon Snow
you have the Dothraki putting Daenerys
down calling her a queen of nothing and
you had the faith militant talking about
the weak masses rising up and rebelling
against people like the Lannisters the
people in power so it was just a big hat
tips of the battles that they were going
to be happening during the season then
about a month after that in February
they released a Hall of faces teaser
which is the characters mocked up like
they were in the Hall of faces they had
dyed all the characters that were still
alive so you just left a wonder who is
going to die next whose faces will be
stolen very cool very ambiguous also
still continuing the mystery of Jon
Snow's fate even though most of us had
already made up our minds one way or
another what was going to happen to him
the first real trailer like the genuine
red band trailer with all the crazy
footage didn't really drop till that
second week in March are you afraid you
should be you're in the great game now
in the great games terrifying
12-inch creatures we deserve to have we
all feel one way or another so that was
two and a half months after they
finished filming so even though they've
been sitting on it for a little while
they tend to wait and include stuff from
all of the episodes it's not just the
first couple of episodes in that trailer
just charting the timeline that would
mean that we might not get a version of
that this year for season seven all the
way till May which sounds like a huge
bummer but that doesn't mean that we're
not going to get teasers get promotional
material for season seven see footage or
anything at all they're going to be
promoting it really soon in South by
Southwest is coming up in March and even
though they took the whole of phases
exhibit to South by Southwest last year
they're bringing sophie Turner Maisie
Williams in both Dan and Dave for a big
panel meaning that they are going to
show something off so there will be a
teaser it might not be exactly like the
red band trailer last year but it'll be
close you have to remember that even at
comic-con they released a teaser just
showing all the production stuff
happening behind the scenes showing you
some of the maps the places that the
characters were going to be going so
even if there's not a ton of new footage
there's always a ton of information to
pour over in the teasers that they drop
so that's probably what's going to be
happening this March so it's still a
little ways off but we are within sight
of new Game of Thrones Season seven
dropping so for all of you asking the
new season they still haven't confirmed
a premiere date but it's likely going to
be sometime in the middle maybe even
late June they could totally choose to
drop that premiere date when there is
South by Southwest oh by the way you're
going to be getting all these episodes
this date in June but a lot of times it
just has to do with the marketing plans
behind the scenes because there's a
giant machine that pushes Game of
Thrones on the world after it's done
being made so they just have to decide
how they're going to market season 7
because we know about some of the big
conflicts and they always do different
things each year the banner teasers in
the Hall of faces trailers those were
the weirdest things they did last year
so they're going to try and cook up
something really cool this year but
everybody's converging on Westeros so
just expect them to hit how Stark House
Targaryen House Lannister in the same
way they did last year when we get a
little closer
doing more than just weekly bonus videos
Oster doing at least a couple Game of
Thrones videos a week so if there any
topics that you guys want me to cover or
videos that I haven't done yet there's a
lot of rumors about Aria's dire wolf
maybe coming back but I'm always up in
the air about rumors and stuff like that
people have been really weird about that
this year like if something may happen
people treat it as a spoiler so it's
hard to talk about without making it
sound like a spoiler so it's hard to
explain dire wolf without talking about
stuff that's happening behind the scenes
so you guys can let me know what kind of
Game of Thrones videos you want me to do
what's going to happen next is my
schedules changed a little bit during
the week freeing up some space on
Thursdays a lot of you been asking for a
new Varys Targaryen restoration
Littlefinger video so I'll probably do
something about that next there been
some really big changes from the books
and that story live because we've moved
past it and they've cut out people like
Aegon wholesale so I'll try to explain
some of those changes but there is a new
round of the book giveaway it is for one
of the enhanced editions of the books
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Richard Clark please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys in the next video
that's going to be my Walking Dead
episode later tonight while you wait for
that to post you can click here to learn
about the Jon Snow White Walkers night
king series and you can click here to
learn all about sonses problems in
season 7
you